c'est la plus grande catastrophe
ferroviaire que paris ait connu le
dernier bilan qui nous est parvenu vers
12h30 fait état donc de 50 morts
l'accident est survenu à une heure de
grand trafic entre paris et la banlieue
c'est à dire autour de 19h hier soir on
évalue à environ 1000 personnes
le nombre de passagers à bord des deux
trains celui qui était à quai en gare de
lyon et l'autre dont les freins n'ont
pas fonctionné et qui s'est encastrée
dans le premier nous allons revenir bien
sûr sur les circonstances de l'accident
nous irons ensuite en direct à la gare
de lyon rejoint de pascal deschamps pour
voir où on en est des opérations de
sauvetage mais tout de suite le drame
qu'ont vécu tous ces passages
aucun mouvement est assez fort pour
décrire cette catastrophe des visions
d'horreur aussitôt après le choc
les secours sont pourtant arrivés très
vite il faut leur rendre hommage le samu
et les sapeurs pompiers la croix rouge
l'assistance publique et toute la nuit
une reporter ont suivi leur tentative
désespérée pour sauver les passagers
reportage agnès poirier et
deux trains de banlieue au chevet très
mal gré la fouille des secouristes de
150 pompiers
les scies à métaux résonne sous les
plafonds du québe du troisième sous sol
de la gare de lyon luttent et lutter
contre les secondes précieuses qui
s'écoule combattre la tôle l'amas de
ferraille qui emprisonne les passagers
l'opération porte officiellement ce nom
terrible d incarcération
vision d'horreur pour les pompiers ces
corps déchiquetés sous le choc
ces corps que l'on extrait avec
précaution même s'ils sont unanimes et
toute la nuit le commandant viger nous
informe de l'ampleur de la catastrophe
le nombre de morts s'accumulent d'heure
en heure grave on était les victimes
gisent sous des bâches en plastique
à l'extérieur de la gare le pc du samu
15 ambulance de réanimation
une vingtaine l'équipe de médecins
anesthésistes l'accès aux zones de soins
est interdite aux curieux dans le hall
les familles angoissées attendent
silence peur panique
le commandant vigie rassure tente
d'expliquer aux uns et aux autres que
tout le monde fait le maximum et vers
une heure du matin c'est le soulagement
pour certains les listes des blessés
évacués sont enfin affiché lui le drame
se poursuit sur le quai b au troisième
sous-sol à 3 heures du matin le bilan
est de 16 morts et puis il ya cette
lueur d'espoir trois personnes vivantes
ont été repérés par les pompiers
découper des tôles
de nous approcher des ailes un médecin
est auprès d'elle à perfuser cette
personne est en train de les soigner
pendant ce temps des coupes autour et
petit à petit on attendait les dégager
rapidement un bloc opératoire est
improvisé sur le quai constat tragique
des médecins il va falloir amputé des
deux jambes l'une de ces trois personnes
coincées sous la ferraille miraculeux
cette jeune fille est enfin libéré
transporté dans une couverture de survie
sa vie est encore en danger elle a passé
12 heures comprimé entre deux wagons
longue très longue nuit pour tous les
secouristes épuisé
au lever du jour il n'y a plus d'espoir
de retrouver des survivants
à présent il faudra à l'aide d'engins
des en-cas strella motrices ou laquelle
il ya toujours de nombreux corps
maintenant le film de ce drame nous
allons remonter donc à hier soir 19h10
au moment du choc dans la gare
souterraine de paris lyon quand le melun
paris a percuté un train de banlieue qui
devait rejoindre lui maisons alfort un
tel accident suppose bien sûr que l'on
n'est plus dans la normale des choses
au total aucun système de sécurité n'a
pu fonctionner il n'a même pas été
possible de défier le train qui entrait
en gare sur une voie de garage
hervé brusini violence du choc le train
percuté s'est ouvert en deux entre ses
flancs il y à la motrice du paris melun
19h04 y hier la rame en instance de
départ pour villeneuve saint georges val
s'ébranlait avec quelques minutes de
retard les voitures sont bondées des
voyageurs des employés la sncf aussi
aperçoivent un convoi qui arrive sur eux
à vive allure
ils n'ont que le temps de sauter hors
des voitures dans le paris melun le chef
du train a prévenu les passagers de
l'imminence d'une collision
voici le témoignage d'une rescapée elle
se trouvait dans la voiture qui était en
poney
après on avait plein de pouvoir en
sortir mais il y avait tellement de gens
qui étaient plus coincé que moi encore
il y avait un monsieur qui était sur mon
dos et oublier qu'il pouvait plus
respirer
c'est petit bougé sam écrasait un peu
plus j'ai pas même dix mois fauche bouge
et il a considéré comme 2
de retard y aurait eu moins de monde
dans ce train là du fait du retard il ya
est équivalent de deux trains seul train
c'est pour ça qu'on était l'ombre qui
avait une petite grand mère qui était
monté avec sa petite fille et qui avait
été sa soirée mort ou faux nom qu'elle
était contre la motrice je pense que la
copie en sortir je la connaissais pas
mes rêves j'ai pensé cette petite fille
j'ai beaucoup d'enfants et c'est l'image
que vous garderez nous par chance cette
femme là que nico de casser
hier soir l'émotion était également
partagé par toutes les personnalités qui
se sont rendus sur les lieux
alors justement maintenant il va falloir
établir les responsabilités l'homme la
machine le système
quelle est la part de chacun de ces
facteurs le train qui arrivait de melun
avait déjà vous l'avez entendu été
victime d'un incident technique qui
mettait en jeu les freins plus tard le
conducteur avait t-il le moyen de
prévenir la gare quand son train est
devenu fou ou encore vous demandez
peut-être ne peut-on interrompt plus ou
moins brutalement bien sûr un train qui
est à propulsion électrique
nous allons reparler des problèmes de la
sécurité avec les premières réactions
des syndicats
et cette première question toutefois
est-il possible d'assurer une sécurité
totale en tout cas dans cette
catastrophe
il y a bien eu défaillance patrick
esther hier soir vers 18h55 sur la voie
numéro deux de la gare souterraine de
paris lyon le train pour villeneuve
saint georges est à quai un autre train
parti de melun se dirige au même instant
vers paris lorsque cette rame de
banlieue arrive à proximité de vert de
maisons
un passager va tirer le signal d'alarmé
ce qui entraîne l'arrêt automatique de
la ram acte de malveillance probable
dire à la direction de la sncf
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à cet instant là
les freins fonctionne parfaitement pour
réenclencher le système
le conducteur doit même descendre de la
motrice puis lemelin paris repart il est
à 8 km du terminus son trajet est suivi
par le poste de régulation de paris sud
est
le conducteur aperçoit un premier signal
jaune mais la vitesse est réduite
il sait qu'il peut facilement arrêter le
train si le feu suivant est au rouge
et effectivement le feu suivant est au
rouge
le conducteur déclenché les freins ceci
ne répondent pas il ne reste plus que
six cents mètres avant l'entrée en gare
il prévient par radio le poste de
régulation il sait déjà que dans trente
secondes son train va percuter quelque
part
devant lui il reste beaucoup
d'aiguillage pour dévier le train fou
mais les aiguilleurs n'ont que quelques
secondes pour choisir un nouvel
itinéraire
ils doivent éviter de faire se percuter
deux convois en marche et qui sont
nombreux à cette heure d'affluence
ils doivent aussi éviter d'envoyer le
convoi vers la gare aérienne le train en
défonçant les butoir pourrait tuer des
centaines de personnes dans le hall le
sort est joué lemelin paris se dirige
vers la voie numéro deux de la gare
souterraine où le pari villeneuve saint
georges en retard sur l'horaire est
encore inquiet à 60 kilomètres/heure la
motrice a percuté et perforer la ramie
mobile en broyant les malheureux
passagers
deux agents de la sncf inculpé
d'homicide et de blessures involontaires
dans la catastrophe de la gare de lyon
c'était il ya 15 morts à l'accident
avait fait rappelez-vous 56 morts les
deux inculpés sont le conducteur du
train percute heures et celui qui
veillait à la fermeture des portes du
train a percuté les deux inculpations
indigne bien sûr les syndicats de
cheminots agnès poirier
56 morts pour un enchaînement de
circonstances c'est ce qu'avaient conclu
la commission d' enquête le 27 juin 88
une passagère tire le signal d'alarmé
dans le train melun paris la ram
s'immobilisant garde vert de maisons
quand le mécanicien redémarre vers la
gare de lyon ils croient les freins
desserré en fait la conduite générale de
pression les freins a été fermée par
mégarde
seuls les freins de la motrice vérifié
par le mécanicien répondent encore s'il
avait suivi les recommandations du guide
de dépannage précise le rapport d'
enquête
il aurait pu faire face à la situation
mais ce texte touchant à la sécurité est
précisément mal écrit difficile à
interpréter précise la commission
denquête le train des valves vers la
gare de lyon le mécanicien lance un
appel radio toews et cuillères et
ordonne aux voyageurs de se réfugier au
fond de la ram c'est le choc
à plus de 70 km heure le train percute
un autre convoi de voyageurs convoi qui
aurait dû être parti depuis deux minutes
mais le contrôleur chargé de veiller à
la bonne fermeture des portes avait pris
du retard dans son service
à l'annoncé de l'inculpation du
mécanicien du train percuteur et du
contrôleur du train à l'arrêt et
syndicats se sont alignés pour nous si
responsable il ya c'est la direction de
la sncf et les pouvoirs publics tout
seul tout seul parce que la politique
qui est menée depuis des années et qu'on
a appelée nous la politique du risque
calculé c'est bien la direction les
pouvoirs publics qui l'amène se sont pas
les cheminots eux ils la subissent
en signe de protestation une grève de
quelques heures à l'appel de la cfdt
risque demain la gare de lyon de
perturber le trafic
[Musique]